[Musique]
bonjour ses envies de lecture matelly
wolf dont canon bonjour patrice carmouze
on va essayer de donner envie de lire
nos téléspectateurs et on va commencer
avec un invité formidable puisqu'il
s'agit de pierre lemaitre bien le maître
bonjour bonjour
alors évidemment le grand public le très
grand public même vous vous connais de
puis au revoir là haut qui le prix
goncourt en 2013 qui se situe dans
l'immédiate après guerre de 1914
c'est le premier tome d'une trilogie
durera ensuite couleurs de l'incendié
qui nous entraîne dans la france des
années 30 puis miroir de nos peines qui
se dérouleront dans cette période
incroyable que vit la france
entre avril et juin 1940 et si tout va
bien parce que vous vous attachez à des
personnages secondaires que vous qu'ils
deviennent des personnages principaux
dans les romans suivants et nous nous y
attachons aussi il y aura peut-être un
quatrième tome de la trilogie deviendra
une quadrilogie si on n'a pas besoin de
maçons et je vous apporte je la porte
une formation n'ira pas peut-être il y
aura sûrement un quatrième tome puisque
il est quasiment terminée je vais le
livret dans quelques temps quelques
semaines dans quelques mois
hamon à mon éditeur voilà avec génial et
alors vous avez commencer évidemment par
le polar c'est peut-être que les gens le
savent - avec des romans comme le
travail soigné robe de mariée cadre noah
alex dans laquelle ils règlent souvent
que les victimes ne soient pas toujours
des victimes que les coupables ne soient
pas toujours des coupables mais nathalie
c'est d'autre chose que vous parle
aujourd'hui
et oui on va parler d'un dictionnaire et
puis de sur quoi un dictionnaire
amoureux dictionnaire amoureux du polar
paru chez plon en moins d'octobre
dernier
alors pierre lemaître bonjour est
d'abord un mot peut-être sur le titre de
ce dictionnaire amoureux le polar c'est
vrai que les français font une
distinction entre romans policiers et
roman noir le premier serait aurait
plutôt pour objectif de résoudre un
crime et le deuxième aurait plutôt une
dimension sociale alors je reprends vos
mots ce serait d'un côté agatha christie
et de l'autre james ellroy
en réalité on peut trouver plein
d'exemples de contre exemple alors pour
vous qu'est ce que le polar
et en exergue de votre dictionnaire vous
citer manuel vazquez montalban qui dit
toute littérature sans exception se
divisant roman d'amour et en romans
policiers je suppose que vous partagez
cette affirmation
oui alors elle me paraît intéressante à
l'otago pour essayer de répondre à votre
première question ce qu'est ce que c'est
que le pool house que le roman noir
j'ai mis à peu près 600 pages pour
essayer de démontrer que c'était très
difficile à expliquer alors là vous me
demander de le faire pour les
téléspectateurs
en quelques minutes en vérité ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que le genre est
maintenant extrêmement multiforme et qu'
un certain nombre de registres de la
littérature empruntent maintenant des
très rares romans policiers ou aux
romans noirs
ce qui fait que le spectre on pourrait
tenir le spectre littéraire du roman
noir s'est beaucoup élargi à un certain
nombre de romans qui sont en quelque
sorte d entre eux deux qui sont un peu
de romans noirs un peu des polars il ya
une affaire criminelle mais il n'y a pas
d' enquête bref tout ça est un détachant
un petit peu large
alors vous avez raison vazquez montalban
il simplifie beaucoup les choses en
disant il ya d'un côté le roman d'amour
leur côté le poids là je crois que ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut entendre c'est
que d'une manière générale il ya deux de
grands volets à la littérature c'est
d'un côté la psychologie seller l'amour
dont c'est en quelque sorte l'acmé et
puis quand on côté le social la
criminalité la rupture avec le monde
social donc pourrait dire que ce que
fait vasquez montalban c'est au moins
ils catégorise deux grands pans de la
littérature qui ne s'opposent pas et qui
souvent ce mari l'a l'autre red bull
cola et dans vos romans policiers il y
avait toujours une liste de livres qui
vous avez inspiré ça va deux roustes
enfin c'est donc beaucoup de discours
que vous lisez que vous citez pardon et
ça va même plus loin puisque dans ce
travail soigné le criminel reproduit des
façons d'opérer qu'il a lu dans des
livres ça commence par exemple par
american psycho de bret easton ellis
alors
et robe de mariée alors j'ai appris en
lisant ce dictionnaire vous avez été
aspiré par un une phrase de paix règle
dans la vie mode d'emploi
alors je voulais montrer pour vous un
polar c'est plus un exercice
intellectuel ou un jeu littéraire
alors c'est là qu'il est peut-être utile
de faire le distinguo entre polar et et
romans noirs
le polar dans le sens où c'est une
énigme et une enquête
tiens beaucoup plus vous avez raison du
de l'exercice intellectuel parce que là
il faut aussi reconstruire une histoire
une intrigue avec des rebondissements
défaut des fausses pistes du suspense il
faut que tout soit bien à sa place et on
pourrait dire que là il faut une
mécanique d'art hâtive tellement bien
soignée qui effectivement vous avez
raison de parler d'un jeu intellectuel
en revanche si on est plutôt du côté du
roman noir du monde social si on
essayait plutôt d'essayer de décrypter
le ce que ce qu'elle a la réalité du
monde
alors là on est moins dans l'exercice
intellectuel parce qu'on est plus dans
l'émotionnel des personnages à qui il
arrive des choses auxquelles le lecteur
a tenté de s'identifier
donc j'ai envie de dire s'il ya du jeu
intellectuel c'est plutôt du côté du
polar alors vous parler d'un livre que
peut-être enfin ce qui est une nouvelle
que peut-être de beaucoup de gens quand
est ce qu'il est que le double
assassinat de la remorque derrière
d'autres gars comme on dit souvent
qu'elle guerre possède l'inventeur des
polars d'ailleurs vous dites qu'on
retrouve dans cette nouvelle tous les
ingrédients qui vont faire les bons pour
l'heure il ya notamment le flic qui
s'appelle du pain dans cette nouvelle et
qui est un type solitaire qui est un
type un peu désabusé pourquoi pourquoi
les pourquoi les flics dans les polars
sont toujours misanthrope désabusé
solitaire pas très heureux alors vous
savez le le polar c'est un saiz hall un
moment de crise un puisqu'il ya un crime
on pourrait dire que le crime et est
l'aboutissement d'un moment de crise
alors on imagine assez mal un enquêteur
primesautier détendu souriant enquêter
sur une crise sociale familiale ou
psychologique
ah oui s'il ya que ce qui collerait pas
et puis je pense qu'il ya aussi autre
chose il ya d'une certaine manière un
mimétisme entre l'enquêteur
l'environnement de son enquête le flic
on pourrait dire est souvent la
métaphore du monde social et comme le
monde social est en crise ben enquêteur
est en crise lui aussi c'est assez
homogène comme ensemble oui alors que
serait au fond le polar idéal vous le
définissez un peu comme aux spoilers
vous dit ce serait un roman dans lequel
il y aurait une surprise à la deuxième
ligne et dont le rebondissement final ne
serait qu'à la dernière ligne
quand vous écrivez vous-même vous
essayez de vous rapprocher de cet idéal
alors écoutez le la question de savoir
ce que c'est que le polar idéal ça nous
fait vraiment penser à la définition de
la femme idéale
la familiale moi j'ai envie de vous dire
c'est celle dont vous tombez amoureux
il n'y a pas de femme idéale il ya
celles qui est un moment vous convient
voilà je pense que c'est pareil pour le
pas là vous avez des peurs qui sont
relativement mal ficelé mais qui vous
plaisent énormément et les plats qui
sont très loin de vous mais qui sont
excellents mais tin vous parle pas bref
trouver le polar idéal ça voudrait dire
presque d'avoir en face le le lecteur
idéal je crois que c'est une distinction
qui peuvent à se faire alors moi j'ai
pas d'idée à la littérature
j'essaie de faire de monter mon histoire
le mieux possible pour qu'elle soit
intéressante pour le lecteur en fait
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un polar c'est un
endroit où on a envie de dire quelque
chose sur le monde et pour dire quelque
chose sur le monde il faut essayer
d'intéresser le lecteur est souvent la
manière dont l'intrigué est monté et
bien c'est plus ou moins la garantie qu
votre lecteur va être intéressé par
votre histoire peut-être même rap et par
votre histoire et qui ne va pas lâcher
le livre avant la dernière page c'est
pour ça que réserver des rebondissements
jusqu'à la fin c'est plutôt une garantie
de bonne fin pour un pur à romans
policiers quand c'est possible et quand
vous écrivez vous-même
alors il ya les polars il ya les romans
comme comme au revoir là haut est ce que
vous savez exactement où vous allez
quand vous écrivez un roman noir est est
ce que vous voulez c'est plutôt divaguer
votre imagination quand vous écrivez des
romans comme voir là-haut ou couleur de
l'interdît ou alors une seule chine si
question rom intéressante parce que
par exemple aragon disait que au fond
lui il écrivait pour voir ce qui allait
se passer
les minimes étaient des personnages au
début et qu'il écrivait pour essayer de
voir comment ça allait se finir
moi je dois dire que comme je n'ai pas
le talent d'aragon si je board pas
simplement une histoire je vais dans le
mur donc moi j'ai plutôt 30 ans à être
précautionneux et puis en même temps je
n'avance pas dans une histoire sans
savoir où je vais surtout dans un polar
parce que eux ne pas savoir où on va
dans un polar sassou pose souvent qu'on
va bricoler la fin est un polar il a su
il pose un énorme problème par rapport
aux au goût du lecteur sait que au fond
très fréquemment un point l'arrêt jugés
en fonction de sa femme si vous avez un
roman un peu médiocre avec une
formidable
vous allez rester sur cette feuille je
dirais trouvé que le livre est
formidable par contre nous mais
l'inversé est aussi vrai donc je envie
de dire soigner vraiment la fin parce
que cette garantie de bonne fin
c'est aussi d'une certaine manière ce
qui va indexer le goût du lecteur donc
moi j'ai tendance à penser qu'une
histoire bienvenue et une histoire bien
construite et qu'on apprend 10 pendant
la construction d'une maison
c'est un travail soigné pour reprendre
le dit document titre que vous n'aimez
pas d'ailleurs m'enfin bon nathalie
willy aussi une ouverture aux mots pulp
ou connais le film paul wilson bien sûr
de tarantino à l'origine de ce monde
c'est autre chose et s'explique
peut-être dites vous la sortie du mépris
dans lequel le polar a longtemps été
tenue c'est quoi la pub sexuelle alors
la sortie du mépris et en même temps son
entrée dans le mépris parce que là
veulent
au fond c'est cette école qui a un peu
inventé le roman le roman policier
populaire c'était aux etats-unis c'était
destiné à des publics de petits lecteurs
c'était d'ailleurs le mot pulp vient du
fait qu'on a pris mais ça sur du papier
qui était avec la pulpe du bois c'est à
dire en fait vendre du papier de
mauvaise qualité
vraiment pas cher à beaucoup de monde et
du coup ça fait sortir un petit peu le
le polar salle a fait émerger le sortent
du champ d être mais en même temps c'est
ce qui a fait sa tâche indélébile sont
d'origine populaire
le fait qu'il y avait énormément de
romans médiocre l'obligation de s'y
réaliser le feuilletonner faisait que
l'on additionnait les intrigues les unes
après les autres qu'ils étaient de moins
en moins intéressante et le plus souvent
médiocre sur le plan littéraire est une
certaine manière le polar c'est très
très mal remis de ce qu'a fait le pulp
donc en fait on pourrait dire c'est un
bilan très contrasté
c'est à la fois l'émergence d'un genre
et en même temps sa cible le prosaïsme
de ses origines qui n'ont pas mon avis
le roman policier ne s'est jamais
véritablement rolf la retrouve des deux
ouvertures dans ce dictionnaire sur tous
les grands auteurs de polars il ya même
il ya même une échappée vers le cinéma
avec des gens comme hitchcock et puis
beaucoup de français aussi et il ya
évidemment agatha christie ça vous
pouviez pas le l'oublier même si vous
dites vous aurez eu envie de big air un
peu plus de balles que vous ne le faites
je me suis déçu un peu moins même
et justement alors lui cette polémique
récente sur les vous parlez des dix
petits
maintenant on peut plus appeler ça des
dix petits mais d'ailleurs relevé
qu' on peut un peu on peut on doit
ouais on doit ouais ouais on doit doit
patrice on doit vous savez on dans 1984
george orwell montre un personnage
s'appelle winston je crois et qui
travaille au ministère de la vérité et
son rouleau c'est de réécrire les
archives du passé pour qu'elles soient
cohérentes avec l'idéologie actuelle et
en fait quand on essaye de déboulonner
les statues canton et sa fin mais quand
on quand on rebâtit ce des livres on ne
fait rien d'autre que faire winston
c'est qu'on essaie d'arranger en
permanence l'histoire pour qu'elle colle
avec le présent moi je pense qu'il faut
revendiquer l'histoire faut être
critique faut être analytique faut être
lucide faut être dénonciateur quand
c'est justifié
mais ça n'est pas en mettant la
poussière sous le tapis qu'on va faire
une bonne histoire une bonne de bonnes
sciences sociales et qu'on va avoir des
enfants bien construit je pense
exactement l inverse
nathalie vous êtes très contente parce
que ça s'arrête à w 1
oui patrice mon nom de famille wolf a
bien aimé cette idée dictionnaire qui
s'arrêtent w puis avec un exercice comme
ça très très rigoureux est ce que c'est
un pied de nez frais de taille au bout
de l'alphabet où il fera qu'avec patrice
à nous ça nous a bien plu
alors pierre lemaître est ce que votre
alphabet s'arrête à cette lettre ou
est-ce que vous n'avez rien trouvé au
rôle très écouté je vous me posez la
question je ne m'en suis pas rendu
compte c'est vous qui m'a invité à
l'instant mais je ne l'avais pas vu qui
manquait xy scène
ce serait à refaire naturellement je
trouverais quelque chose mais je les
âges
donc voilà je j'avoue très honnêtement
ça m'a échappé lors des autopsies vous
voulez dans un indicateur comme ça on
n'a pas un cahier des charges qui fait
qu' il faut se servir qu'une fenêtre
c'est justement le jeu du dictionnaire
amoureux d'avoir les injustices par
exemple d'oublier les trois dernières
lettres c'est tout rapidement parce
qu'il faut qu'on se quitte
malheureusement ça passe trop vite avec
vous est ce que vous auriez un conseil
de lecture nous à nous donner
est-ce que vous avez le temps de
relancer j'en aurai pas un méchant nord
et 3 mais rassurez vous je vais les
trois fois plus vite une date lointaine
1964 c'est un bouquin de jim thompson
qui s'appelle 1275 âmes qui est un roman
jubilatoire
excellentissime d'un immense auteur qui
est mort dans le gant absolument méconnu
et qui aujourd'hui est considéré comme
un des maîtres du genre
plus près de nous il faut aller voir le
couperet de donald wesley compétences 97
quand ça paraît une histoire absolument
formidable sur le chômage des seniors
c'est le monde social tel qu'il est en
97 rien n'a changé 23 ans plus tard et
puis aujourd'hui quelque chose de plus
actuel le magnifique diptyque de
deux des rois c'est un auteur français
son diptyque l'appel pour tous et son
windows
c'est un roman planétaire sur
l'interconnexion des dégâts
contemporaine ça vous qu'un apps c'est
en somme un diptyque absolument de
formidables donc voilà jim thompson
donald westlake et des hauts et bas
merci infiniment pierre lemaître je vais
donc dictionnaire amoureux du pôle a
cessé plomb et puis on attend le comme
vous faites j'ai rien comme personne le
quatrième tome de votre trilogie redoux
va bientôt et merci infiniment pierre
merci
[Musique]